uh the world Athletics Council has
already made a number of important
decisions regarding the future
participation of the Russian and Bella
Russian Athletics federations and the
amendment of Eligibility regulations for
athletes who are transgender and who
have differences of sexual development
DSD
the council agreed to the reinstatement
of the Russian Federation Rusev
following seven years of suspension and
that of course was due to the egregious
institutional doping violations however
athletes officials and supporting
personnel
from Russia and Belarus are still
excluded from competition for the
foreseeable future due to Russia's
invasion of Ukraine